being done to support our hospitals
right now
at fema we've been part of this cove
admission since day one i'm beginning
with supporting jurisdictions with
medical personnel acquiring and shipping
personal protective equipment
medical equipment opening testing sites
and deploying federal resources in
support of our state local territorial
and tribal members
as we approach the one-year anniversary
of opening our first community
vaccination center in california just
one of the thousands we supported across
the country
fema and our over 20 000 strong
workforce continues to meet the ongoing
requirements of the pandemic
our support to our partners hasn't
stopped and will not stop until this
pandemic is over
we know that the most critical need
right now is medical staffing for our
hospitals and we've been working
non-stop with the departments of defense
and health and human services who have
been on the grounds in communities since
day one
to push even more medical teams out the
door to communities who need it most
i've seen firsthand the impacts of these
teams on their continued heroic efforts
during my time as commissioner in new
york city
for emergency management at the very
beginning of this pandemic i had the
privilege of speaking with the chief
nursing officer at elmhurst hospital
which was at the time the epicenter of
the epicenter in those very early days
and listened to her arrest the
department of defense medical team as
they were concluding their mission at
their hospital
she said with tears in her eyes you were
the miracle we needed when we needed it
most
dod continues to deliver on those
miracles every day as they stand
shoulder to shoulder with the heroes
working on the front line in your
communities
yesterday
i spoke with governors whitmer and
dewine who both said separately that
these teams in addition to adding more
clinical capacity
are a morale boost to the doctors the
nurses and the support staff in
hospitals that came in
and working day and night to save lives
so now dod is deploying six additional
teams to ohio michigan rhode island new
jersey new york and new mexico
we will also be deploying an additional
hhs team to rhode island
and in the next several weeks we are
prepared to do more
these teams are in addition to more than
than the more than thousand staff that
are already deployed to 26 states two
territories the district of columbia and
24 tribal nations
and since march of 2020 since the
beginning of this pandemic thousands of
federal personnel have deployed all over
our country
as critical as our doctors and nurses
are countless other professionals keep
our hospitals running
patient transporters
food workers and cleaning staff are all
at the heart of these health care
facilities
and so for that reason with the
president's support i am now directing
an expansion of our fema policy to
permit funding to states who elect to
use their national guard troops to fill
these critical support roles in
hospitals
during every disaster fema's strength is
our ability to coordinate with other
straight stakeholders federal state
local tribal private and non-profit
partners
to identify gaps and meet needs
and this cove admission has been no
different
we meet with our dod hhs and other
federal partners
daily to anticipate future needs and
fill those requests
fema has also been supporting
communities across the country through
nearly 100 billion dollars in funding
for all types of covid related needs
including vaccination
safely opening and operating schools and
other public facilities
and testing thanks to an unprecedented
commitment by this administration
this funding combined with the
extraordinary work of dod hhs and our
other federal partners
has enabled states and local communities
to fight this pandemic save lives and
protect families
this pandemic has shifted and changed
through the delta variant and now the
omicron variant but our commitment
and the commitment of the entire fam
federal family has not changed together
we will continue to surge staff
push resources and provide support using
every tool that we have available to
fight our fight against covet 19.
thank you i'll take a few questions all
right
thank you thank you for being here
administrator
manpower is one thing but i know you've
talked about in the past too having to
make sure they have somewhere to work
and that there are hospital beds so for
these same particular states and
hospitals that have been identified are
you building out capacity adding
more
physical space for the teams to work in
these specific states these six states
we are just sending staff that is the
request that they had um our regional
administrators have been in constant
communication with our state emergency
management directors and state public
health directors
throughout this pandemic and we have
been conducting recently facility
expansion assistance
to all of the states
right now we've had a few states that
have requested some assistance in
helping to identify where they may be
able to expand but we've had no specific
requests to expand hospital capacity
outside of maybe setting up a tent
outside of their emergency room to be
able to support
um traders know this has been a year of
unprecedented um natural disasters as
well as obviously global pandemic that
has no uh end in sight at this point
are you largely relying on arp funding
or are you hoping to get more funding
from the administration going forward as
we're looking at another year of ongoing
challenges yeah the funding that fema
uses is through our disaster relief fund
and right now for all the requirements
that we have um on our plate we have
enough funding within that um to meet
all of those demands
thank you administrator for doing this
um what kind of feedback were you
getting from governors or hospitals that
led to this decision and this added
flexibility and then secondly i'm also
wondering you know next week there's i
guess 120 military members going as part
of the six state deployment that's out
of the i think 1 000 military members
the president has said he would mobilize
uh this coming month so why are you only
sending 120 right now at a time when
there are you know nearly two dozen
states i think that have 85 plus icu bed
capacity are there not more requests
coming in or what are you waiting for to
deploy the rest of that 1000 yeah great
questions and so on on the first
question um remind me the first question
again real fast the feedback that you're
getting from governors so yes so again
my regional administrators they've been
communicating with our state directors
daily and one of the things that um that
we have heard recently is
while we do need medical staffing
there's a lot of other functions within
the hospital that need additional
staffing in particular because of the
omicron variant and how it's taking
other staff within the hospital out and
so we've been able to expand our policy
in order to make sure that we're
providing whatever type of resources are
available
to keep those hospitals functioning so
an incredible step forward to make sure
that they can keep moving
as far as where we're at with the
deployment of personnel going out the
department of defense i'm
through fema we have been sending
department of defense personnel out
throughout this pandemic we sent several
teams out during the delta surge
and we started to evaluate what we
thought the impacts would be for the
omicron variant earlier in december
that's where the initial announcement
was made that we were going to send a
thousand additional personnel from the
department of defense as we get requests
from our state partners for what they
need these are the requests that we have
right now and we're filling those based
on when they can receive
them i thank you for the question so
what's the point of now sending 1095 or
can 95 masks out to americans if a lot
of those masks are just single daily use
like somebody wears it once then what
masks save lives um i think is the
important thing here and we want to make
sure that everybody has the tools and
resources that they need in order to
protect themselves and their families
go in the back
administrator thank you so much for
taking my question i just want to ask
you is there any plan you said your
agency is willing to do more but is
there any plan to set up perhaps and
maps more of those mass
testing sites federally run testing
sites or the vaccination sites to help
stop the spread but also get people
tested we know that you're you're the
administration plan it's not those rapid
tests but the pcr test of course is more
accurate so is there a plan to do more
in some of those hard hit states across
the country
absolutely so again we're working with
our state to identify what their needs
are you know there's many parts of the
country that have built up internal
capacity across their states but those
areas that need that additional listing
sites and we are available except
there's been partnering with the centers
for disease control and we are setting
those up now and we'll continue to do so
you know as the states need them and as
they request them
brian
thanks a lot thanks a lot administrator
uh well you came on in april and uh
fema's had mass vaccination sites that's
rolled out i think that one of the
questions is right now the president
just announced that
they're going to triple the stockpile of
ppe get mass out to americans and also
try to expand uh the testing capacity
and home test kits
did fema wait too much of its resources
for vaccinations or should it have also
been surging that capacity months ago in
testing and ppe
fema's role has always been to support
our hospitals our schools
and our public service agencies we have
been supporting them through the
delivery and reimbursement for ppe for
medical staff that we're sending out
that has not changed and that support
will continue um the additional support
that's coming out for the general
population is something that fema does
not participate in and those are the
issues that or the items that you're
hearing are going to be announced and
available to the general public later
when it comes to testing sites fema's
rolled out public testing sites why not
search public testing sites three months
ago in anticipation that there would be
uh surges of variance again we're
working with our states uh routinely and
we're hearing what their needs are and
we're basing our support to them on what
they need and so as they request
additional assistance that's when we
come together and give them the
assistance that they need
thank you administrator appreciate you
coming you're always welcome and invited
thank you
thank you everyone
okay
um
i know again we have short time here so
i just have uh two items for you at the
top uh since president biden signed the
bipartisan infrastructure law 60 days
ago uh the biden-harris administration
has hit the ground running to deliver
results we've made key progress toward
implementing the largest long-term
investment in america's infrastructure
and competitiveness in nearly a century
the department of transportation today
announced a historic investment under
the bipartisan infrastructure law to
modernize repair and replace
approximately 15 000 bridges nationwide
that's a lot of bridges this is the
single largest dedicated bridge
investment since the construction of the
interstate highway system and provides
more than 27 billion dollars to states
and tribal transportation facilities
obviously there will be more to come and
you'll hear the president soon another
little bit of news for all of you and
we'll have more on the week ahead i
expect in the coming days but next
wednesday the president will hold a
formal press conference at 4 p.m in the
afternoon so we look forward to seeing
you there and to the president looks
forward to speaking directly to the
american people i'm going to try to go
to the people who didn't get questions
and then come back around if that works
so go ahead um i wanted to follow up on
the cyber attack against the ukraine
yeah i know the nfc said it was too soon
to attribute the attack but could you
say where early indications are pointing
well uh let me first say that um the and
just because i know there's been a lot
of questions understandably on this so
let me try to address a few of them as
well if that's okay
um the united states and our allies and
partners are concerned about this cyber
attack and the president has been
briefed we are also in touch with
ukrainians and have offered our support
as ukraine investigates the impact in
nature and recovers from the incidents
we don't have attribution at this time
and i can't point to any more specifics
i know the ukrainians also announced and
conveyed that they got their systems up
and running pretty quickly and that
personal data was not
continue
to of course work with them and assess
any additional impacts we're continuing
to consult with allies and partners
including ukraine on this you might have
also seen nato's statement as well which
says that they are also exchanging
information uh with ukraine so that's
where the status stands right now i
think it's important to note the
ukrainian statements on this which
convey very very clearly that they were
able to get their systems up and running
determined that russia was behind the
attack how would the us respond to that
i'm just not going to speculate on that
or preview what actions we would take
at this time i would just note that we
will take necessary and proper steps of
course to defend our allies support our
partners and support the ukrainian
people but we're still assessing that at
this point in time
in a little more detail what sort of
support the us has been providing
ukraine on the cyber front like over the
last few months
i'm happy to check with our team and see
if we can detail that uh more to all of
you specifically uh we have been in
touch with them working with them on
many levels and certainly
cyber something
such as something
of new throughout europe throughout the
world uh we've providing of course best
practices the expertise we have in the
us government but i can see if we can
detail that more specifically chris go
ahead um i know there have been some
challenges this week but zooming out
kind of even more
uh what's your message to democratic
voters out there who said
they voted for lawmakers to protect
voting rights turn the tide on global
warming lower prescription drug prices
reform police departments raise the
minimum wage tackle student debt and
have gotten none of it
our message to them is that we're still
fighting for absolutely every component
of what you just listed and that uh
right now uh we're dealing with the
realities of the fact that we have a
very slim majority in the senate and in
the house
that makes things more challenging than
they have been in the past i would also
note and i bet a lot of americans who
have conveyed their advocacy for a lot
of those issues issues the president
cares deeply about
have also cared deeply about getting the
pandemic under control have also cared
deeply about ensuring schools are open
across the country that small businesses
are functioning that our economy is up
and running and those have been the top
issues basically in every piece of data
we've seen across the board so the
message from the president to them is he
is committed to continuing to fight
you heard him say this week that voting
rights
the right to people to express their
views at the polls is something that is
fundamental to him and he's going to
stay at it
one last thing do you have any news for
us on the president holding a formal
news conference i just announced one at
the top chris we've just caught
you uh it's okay
i now relate to your teachers in high
school and what they may have
experienced but it's okay
yeah there you go it's a to to be fair
it is a friday uh in a very busy news
week so i will if everybody should take
any any pressure off of chris go ahead
yes go ahead and i we have not met
before so welcome to the briefing room
thank you uh is the president planning
any sort of staff shake-up or changes at
the white house given recent setbacks
including inflation at a 40-year high
the supreme court blocking the vaccine
mandate and the collapse of voting
rights legislation well i would say the
other way to look at the last year is
that
200 million americans are now vaccinated
more than 80 percent of americans have
received at least one dose if you look
back to a year ago only about 35 percent
of people were willing to do that the
president's through the president's
action and leadership we've made
vaccines available across the country
boosters we have provided more supply to
the global community 400 million doses
than any other country in the world
we've had record economic growth in this
country we have record low unemployment
rates in this country and we are getting
out of a pandemic and the the economic
downturn tied to it at a rate that is
faster than anyone thought would have
happened we have confirmed more judges
that look like america that are diverse
like this country than almost any other
administration in history and i guess
the truth is an agenda doesn't wrap up
in one year we are going to continue to
fight for every component of his leg of
his agenda uh and his um and his uh his
plans for his presidency that he
outlined when he was running for
president
um can you confirm that a corona virus
emergency spending request is coming and
what details can you provide on that
well we are always in touch with
congress and leaders in congress about
what needs the american people have as
we continue to fight the pandemic that
has been the case uh
continuously throughout the pandemic um
and that remains the case today i don't
have anything to preview for you but i
would just echo what speaker pelosi said
over the weekend a couple days ago where
she said that we weren't going to let
resources get in the way of fighting the
pandemic that continues to be our view
but i have nothing to preview at this
point time but those conversations are
ongoing go ahead you have a couple of
questions and one from my colleague sure
my first question is um the
administration's responses hundreds of
nurses um with the national nurses
united
health demonstrations demanding for
safer covert conditions and they talked
about there's not necessarily
a
shortage of nurses but many are not
willing to work and what they feel like
are unsafe um conditions and feel like
some of the protections are being
weakened
well i would say first that we believe
there should be strict and stringent uh
requirements um in uh medical uh and and
in hospitals and medical facilities to
keep the people who working there safe
and also to keep the patients safe and i
would just note that yesterday the
supreme court uh continued to um
is allowing for uh this cms requirement
to move forward which is a important
component of keeping uh keeping uh
people who are patients safe but also
keeping workers in a lot of facilities
safe a number of hospital systems across
the country have implemented vaccine
requirements which we certainly support
and they've been very successful with so
we've continued to encourage others to
do the same okay coming in
coming is there anything we can expect
to hear from the president any type of
new strategy any plan and what is he
going to be doing on that day
uh i expect we'll have more details i
certainly
in our history but i expect we'll have
more details for that hopefully in the
next 24 hours
confirmation on that the u.s has
information that indicates russia has
pre-positioned a group of operatives to
conduct a false flag operation in
eastern ukraine as reported by cnn yeah
i do have some detail on this um let me
confirm for you
um
uh so as as you all have heard us say
many times we are concerned that the
russian government is preparing for an
invasion in ukraine that may result in
widespread human rights violations and
war crimes should diplomacy fail to meet
their objectives as part of its plans
russia is laying the groundwork to have
the option of fabricating a pretext for
invasion and we've seen this before we
saw this before leading up to 2014 just
to note
including through sabotage activities
and information operations
then attack
russian forces in eastern ukraine
and the russian military plans to begin
these activities several weeks before
military invasion which could begin
between mid-january and mid february
again we saw this playbook before
including the widespread effort
to push out misinformation not just in
eastern europe but around the global
community we have information that
indicates russia has already
pre-positioned a group of operatives to
conduct a false flag operation in
eastern ukraine the operatives are
trained in urban warfare and in using
explosives to carry out acts of sabotage
against russia's own proxy forces our
information also indicates that russian
influence actors are already starting to
fabricate ukrainian provocations in
state and social media to justify a
russian intervention and so divisions in
ukraine for example russian officials
and influence actors are emphasizing
narratives about the deterioration of
human rights in ukraine and the
increased militancy of ukrainian leaders
this is all the spreading of
misinformation these media narrative
narratives also blame the west for
escalating tension highlight
humanitarian issues in ukraine that
russian intervention could solve and
promote russian patriotism to encourage
domestic support for military action and
finally during december russian language
content on social media covering all
three of these narratives increased to
an average of nearly 3 500 posts per day
a 200 percent increase from the daily
average in november so it's important to
note what people are seeing out there
and to call out this misinformation that
is being spread to uh
as a false flag operation and there's a
number of tactics that they're using in
that regard let me go to the back go
ahead thank you
uh russia's foreign minister sergey
lavrov said today that moscow have run
out of patience
with the west so how passionate is
president biden with russia's aggressive
behavior and another one
uh the afp
news agency reports that ukraine
proposes three-way crisis summit with
president biden putin and zelenski's
you open to such a format
i have nothing to preview in terms of
the next steps on on negotiations or
talks uh everybody's back in their
capitals now having conversations about
that i will note that the president's
view in our view is that this is up to
president putin and russia to determine
what the path for it is we are ready
regardless of what they decide if they
decide they're going to invade ukraine
they're going to be economic
consequences that go far beyond 2014 if
they decide they want to engage in
diplomatic conversations and talks we
are very open to that and we're hopeful
they will do that but ultimately it's a
choice they need to make and so i would
suggest you ask them that question
what about the president vital stations
with uh what russia is again it's not
about that it's about russia deciding
what path they're going to take go ahead
okay
hi so president biden yesterday said
that he will be providing for the
administration will be providing high
quality masks to americans for free yeah
however health experts have been saying
for quite some time now that better
masks are crucial against omicron so why
is the white house
late to making them available for free
we aren't we actually have already
provided 30 million masks across the
country we have built a stockpile of 750
million masks in the government and this
is about uh expanding and building upon
uh providing high quality masks out to
people across the country and i would
say of the
money that uh was used for from the
american rescue plan uh to keep schools
open some of that was used for ppe a lot
of funding that has been uh that has
already been approved over the course of
the last year plus has been used for ppe
as well so this is building on those
steps i just want to get around to
everybody oh go ahead put some more so
come on harry can put in charge of
voting rights uh why wasn't she with the
president at the crucial senate lunch to
sell the bill
well the the uh vice president has been
selling the bill uh across the country
um obviously delivering speeches uh
providing uh engaging and meeting with
activists uh she's also been she was
also working the phones over the last
couple of days and has has played a
pivotal role uh no question we'll
continue to moving forward go ahead
thanks so much oh wait actually let me
just make sure i get to everybody and
then i'll come around go ahead thanks
jeff last march president biden signed
an executive order encouraging federal
agencies to help expand access to the
ballot did you get an update on how
federal agencies have dealt with that um
in the past year or so in terms of how
they've implemented it in steps they've
taken
we can actually absolutely get you one
um and get you one from what agency to
agency what they've been doing and that
was something
yeah in congress could we expect any
more executive orders like that or
actions from the federal government that
don't require congress i will say we are
going to continue to look for ways to uh
protect and expand
the uh rights of the american people to
to have access to voting and in addition
to that executive order uh the
department of justice as you know
doubled their funding and support for
the protection of voting rights
we also have been working with
organizations all across the country who
are building diverse coalitions to pass
pro-voter laws and push back against
against those that make it harder to
vote and threaten free and fair
administration of elections in addition
to doing the critical work to register
and educate voters these organizations
have built grassroots leadership at the
state level including among state
legislators and across the latino
african-american aapi native american
communities among young people and
they're providing also training policy
research messaging guidance and direct
organizing to register voters and
deploying voter protection teams so we
are working uh certainly at the federal
level also at the grassroots level and
we will continue to look for ways to
protect people's fundamental rights
george go ahead yeah i want to go back
to the first year anniversary uh and and
ask you if there's anything that's that
surprised you in the first year and i'm
thinking of a couple things that weren't
being talked about a year ago at
inauguration everybody was excited about
vaccines now you have anti-backs groups
trump was being impeached now he
controls the opposition party
uh and there was no talk of inflation at
the time of uh
well that's happened in a year i would
say you know
actually if we look back at data around
the time or shortly before the
inauguration only about a third of the
american public was willing to get
vaccinated and now we're over 80 so
actually that's an area where there has
been an enormous amount of progress made
there has been some surprising
components including the fact that many
people who were opposed to getting
vaccinated
we assumed that because it was a vaccine
that was approved one of them at least
by under a republican president uh that
the fda had given formal approval in
september and obviously given the dire
impacts of the virus that there wouldn't
be as much vaccine hesitancy
but that's one of the reasons that we
took a number of the steps we did over
the course of the fall um you know i
would say that
of course
you know you look back and there are uh
there are initiatives and uh that the
president for that have historically not
been partisan and that's a surprise but
voting rights is certainly an example of
them and as i've said a few times from
here there are 16 republicans sitting in
the senate who have supported voting
rights uh protections in the past so i'm
not sure if that's surprising but that
certainly is not a development in the
right direction
has he been surprised that the
difficulty in bringing republicans along
to his views
well i think a lot of people are
surprised 19 republicans voted for the
infrastructure bill and five or six
voted in the house in the senate and
five or six voted in the house uh there
are there are again initiatives and
policies that have historically had
bipartisan support like voting rights
that have become unfortunately perceived
as a partisan issue go
that cyber ahead on ukraine uh ukraine's
ambassador here in washington told cbs
news that her country believed that
cyber attack would precede any major
military
action by putin's forces i think you've
touched on this when you're talking
about the groundwork being laid but just
to be more clear does the administration
view
cyber attacks
as a signal that russia
plans to invade
i'm not going to give an assessment of
that from here i would just note it's
also important that to to uh to include
the context of the fact that ukrainian
officials have spoken to the impact of
this specific attack we know that cyber
is a tool that many uh actors across the
world use as a form of warfare uh we
have seen that increase only increase in
recent years but in terms of what the
chain of events uh would be or will be i
just don't have anything more for you on
that
false flag ops that you've talked about
has that changed the assessment of how
probable a military invasion would be
compared to yesterday before these two
incidents i think it gives every clear
picture of what we're seeing in terms of
the preparations um
now and whether or not they move forward
that is up to the russian leaders to
decide but uh the fact that they are
laying out to your point wisa these
false flag operations that they are
sowing the seeds of misinformation uh
that does give you an indication of all
of the preparations that are underway
sure because secretary blinken was very
frank yesterday in an interview and he
said there are just a few weeks left to
reach mutual compliance with iran
because they are just a few weeks away
from having enough material for a
nuclear weapon so
can you talk about what this final push
for an agreement looks like and how
realistic it is given there are only a
few weeks left uh i i of course agree
with secretary blinken i mean i was
gonna say he's absolutely right which
seems like a silly thing to say but i
would note um we said that it is a
critical time is how the president sees
it as well
though there has been some progress made
in negotiations if we don't reach an
understanding soon a mutual return to
compliance we will have to consider a
different path forward and
the bottom line is the president is not
going to allow iran to possess a nuclear
weapon and as secretary blinken noted
they have made progress and this is
no thanks to the
decision by the former president to pull
out of the iran nuclear agreement
despite promises that they would agree
on a stronger agreement that iran would
not move forward they've done exactly
those things exactly those things they
predicted would not happen have happened
that is why we're in the point we are in
but that means several weeks ago the
president asked his team to prepare
a range of options uh they have done
that and obviously our preference is
always diplomacy
oh i got okay peter go ahead last one
thank you president biden promised to
bring decades of dc experience to the
oval office but buildback better has not
passed voting rights apparently not
going to pass and vaccine requirements
that he likes are apparently illegal
what happened
uh well first peter i would say if you
look back at last year and what we were
able to accomplish that include getting
the american rescue plan passed a
package that has uh has contributed to
cutting childhood poverty by 40 percent
has helped ensure we are moving at a
faster pace toward economic growth
toward a record low unemployment rate
helped ensure schools more than 95
percent are open across the country he
also pressed despite skeptics uh to get
a bipartisan infrastructure bill passed
one that we have just we're just
announcing today the fact that 15 000
bridges are going to be repaired that
was despite many skeptics and because of
his efforts 200 million americans are
now vaccinated the work of an
administration continues after one year
and it will he will continue to press
forward on all of
priorities ago and working with
about
those
republicans now he is talking about
republicans that don't agree with voting
rights he's describing them as george
wallace bull connor and jefferson davis
what happened to the guy who when he was
elected said to make progress we must
stop treating our opponents as our enemy
i think everybody listening to that
speech who's speaking on the level as my
mother would say would note that
he was not comparing them as humans he
was comparing the choice uh to those
figures in history and where they're
going to position themselves if they as
they determine whether they're going to
support the fundamental right to vote or
not one last thing the bengals are
playing tomorrow i'm just giving it a
shout out so that my husband will be
excited at home they haven't won a
playoff game in 31 years okay we got to
wrap it up
yes go ahead can i get a quick update on
now that the dust has settled are there
any steps the administration is going to
take going forward with respect to the
vaccine mandate and have you found that
it was a success and then one more
update on yesterday are you guys still
making calls this weekend on voting
rights it seems that mansion and cinema
even after coming to the white house
there's no case that they're going to
change their positions so i mean what
did the next few days look like before
that
well i would say that the president's
view as you heard him say yesterday is
that we're going to continue to press to
get this done moving forward and that
means continuing to engage with a range
of officials
who are supportive some who have
questions and some who are skeptical he
obviously met with senator cinema
yesterday afternoon even after she
made a public speech about um about her
opposition to the filibuster i think
that's evidence of his continued
commitment to keep engaging
as it relates to the vaccine
requirements and and what's next uh as
the president said yesterday the supreme
court has chosen to block common sense
life-saving requirements for employees
uh we're of course immensely
disappointed by that decision it's now
up to the states and individual
employers to put in that place
vaccination requirements here are some
pieces of good news and this is a little
updated from yesterday uh businesses and
other employers have already taken these
steps nearly 40 percent of fortune 100
companies have vaccine requirements
in october prior to the osha rule even
coming out a quarter of workers in the
country were already subject to
requirement from their employer by
january that number had risen to nearly
60 percent of employee of employers
requiring or planning to require
vaccines and since the administration
began implementing requirements in july
we've gotten from 90 million to 30
million americans unvaccinated more work
to be done no question it was good news
that the cms requirement for healthcare
workers was kept in place that will
impact 10 to 11 million and there are a
number of companies across the country
that are good models we're going to
continue to echo those okay i don't want
you to be late go ahead
um did the president move the needle at
all with senators mentioned in cinema as
it relates to voting rights in the
filibuster i will let them give an
assessment of where they stand and um
you know i understand you guys think
this is a fight worth having but are you
clear-eyed at least and are you willing
to tell your supporters to be clear-eyed
that these votes next week on voting
rights and on changing filibuster rules
are going to fail
if we believed everything every pundit
said out there and listen to that the
president would not have run for office
he would not be president we would not
have an infrastructure bill that is law
we we have heard we have heard what
members have said it is important about
where they stand on the filibuster the
president is going to stay at it as you
heard him say yesterday because he
believes that voting rights is a
fundamental right for people across the
country thanks everyone happy friday
you